my name is Helen Hayes I want people to  know that I had an encounter with Bill  Cosby in the summer of 1973 I was  attending the Clint Eastwood celebrity  tennis tournament at Pebble Beach  California with two of my friends bill  followed us around all day Saturday he  found us again on Saturday night even  though we had changed restaurants  several times to avoid him at first we  thought it was all right because it was  daytime and it was Bill Cosby  we felt we were safe but then when he  found us in the last restaurant he  approached me from behind  I reached over my shoulder and grabbed  my right breast I was stunned and angry  because he had no right to do that and I  didn't know why he would behave that way  his behavior was like that of a predator  thank you